Movie production is often viewed as a well
oiled machine on tight, strict schedules for
everyone included.
It often leads moviegoers to assume everything
happens precisely as planned, but that isn’t
always the case.
Improvised scenes usually happen when an actor
truly transforms into their character and
reacts to the any given situation as said
character.
Unscripted scenes give movies a more honest
feel and leave the viewers remembering the
film.
And, more often than not, can spark an emotion
from laughter to sadness—and everything
in between.
Check out these 10 hilarious movie moments
you didn't know were improvised.
Robin Williams & Matt Damon In Good Will Hunting
Matt Damon and Ben Affleck’s critically
acclaimed film, Good Will Hunting, had its
very own hilarious improv scene.
The sequence features whiz kid Will Hunting
(Matt Damon) at one of his many therapy sessions
with therapist Sean Maguire (Robin Williams).
In order to get Hunting to open up emotionally,
Maguire recalls a memory about his late wife
and her gassy habits causing Hunting to laugh
hysterically.
But what you may not have known is the entire
story was made up by Williams mid-scene.
And Damon’s laugh is 100 percent genuine.
Although Williams earned his first and only
Academy Award for his role, he still managed
to dial in his well-known improvised acting
skills at a critical moment.
Jim Carrey & Jeff Daniels in Dumb and Dumber
It’s hard to forget Jim Carey and Jeff Daniels
as the idiotic best buddies Lloyd Christmas
and Harry Dunne in the comedy-cult-classic—Dumb
and Dumber.
And, with a duo like that, is it so hard to
believe that the actors didn’t stick to
the assigned dialogue?
There’s a scene where the two knuckleheads
pick up a hitchhiker and unleash a ton of
crazy antics on the unsuspecting man.
In the original script by the Farrelly Brother’s,
the scene called for Carrey and Daniels to
test the man’s nerves over an argument about
jelly beans.
But instead, the two actors horse around endlessly.
This is the notable scene where Carrey asks,
“Hey, wanna hear the most annoying sound
in the world?” and proceeds to yell in the
man’s ear.
Nick Frost & Simon Pegg in Shaun of the Dead
The 2004 Brit-horror-comedy, Shaun of the
Dead, featured its share of British comedians,
comic actors and sitcom stars leaving the
script open for interpretation from the cast.
That being said, there are several different
versions of the scene where Nick Frost’s
character Ed attempts to cheer up Shaun (Simon
Pegg) by telling stories about the pub regulars.
In the scenes, Ed describes the woman as an
ex-pornstar and this was supposedly all made
up on the spot.
And as a result, we even get some genuine
laughter from Pegg.
Seth Rogan & Paul Rudd in Knocked Up
Judd Apatow’s 2007 rom-com, Knocked Up,
starred Seth Rogen and Katherine Heigl as
two young adults facing the repercussions
of a drunken-one-night stand and an unintended
pregnancy.
The film also featured an improvised scene
idea from Apatow’s 2005 hit The 40-Year-Old
Virgin.
The scene involves Rogan’s character Ben
Stone taking a ride with Pete (Paul Rudd)
where the two perform some hilarious back
and forth banter.
While the scene didn’t make the movie, it
was part of the DVD extra as a deleted bonus
scene and the improvised dialogue runs over
three minutes.
Paul Rudd & Michael Pena in Ant-Man
Marvel’s Ant-Man is arguably one of MCU’s
funniest superhero films and it is largely
due to the hilarious cast.
The film stars Paul Rudd, Michael Pena, Judy
Greer, Evangeline Lily and many more.
And believe it or not, a majority of the stars
scenes were improvised.
Rudd revealed many of his scenes with Greer
(who plays his ex) were improv.
While Pena told Variety that about 50 percent
of his scenes were improvised as well.
Specifically Pena and Rudd’s scenes would
need a re-write as the two would make the
scene their own with the magic of improv.
Bill Murray in Caddyshack
One of Caddyshack’s most quoted scenes from
the film is by Bill Murray’s character,
groundskeeper Carl Spackler.
In the film, Murray mutters a story to himself
about an unknown golfer winning the Masters
and he titles it “The Cinderella Story.”
Unknown to many is that the entire scene was
developed by the actor on the spot.
In his 1999 book Cinderella Story: My Life
in Golf Murray said, "The Cinderella Story
was a spur-of-the-moment idea.
'Get me some flowers,' I said.
'Four rows of mums.”
Harrison Ford in The Empire Strikes Back
Throughout the Star Wars films, Harrison Ford
has played the cocky rogue Han Solo.
In many of the films we see his character
as brash, arrogant, conceited and overconfident
but there is one scene where we see some compassion.
In the original scene in The Empire Strikes
Back before Han is placed in suspended animation
Leia confesses her love Han and is supposed
to reply with “I love you too.”
However, George Lucas told Ford that it doesn’t
work and thought he should say what he thought
would be best.
And with that, we get the simple reply of
“I know.”
Richard Castellano in The Godfather
The Godfather is a dark and gritty crime drama
that follows a fictional New York mafia family.
But one of the actors took it upon himself
to add a bit of comedy to the script.
In the scene when Peter Clemenza (Richard
Castellano) heads out to have Paulie Gatto
(John Martino) killed, his wife also tells
him to remember to pick up cannoli’s.
As a result, the murder takes place during
the cannoli run.
After Clemenza’s henchman takes care of
Gatto, the mafia man instructs his lackey
to “Leave the gun.
Take the cannoli.”
And just like that, the slight tweak and improvised
line of humor created a very memorable moment
in the movie.
Jeremy Renner in Avengers: Age of Ultron
The Marvel’s Cinematic Universe really made
an incredible movie with Avengers: Age of
Ultron.
Fans were introduced to new characters and
it laid the foundation for the Civil War storyline.
Aside from all the action and drama it had
some hilarious scenes, in particular with
Jeremy Renner’s Hawkeye.
He and Quicksilver (Aaron Taylor-Johnson)
had a somewhat love-hate relationship and
often had back-to-back banter.
At one scene, Quicksilver speeds away and
taunts Hawkeye, leaving the archer to draw
his bow and take aim at the speedster, quietly
saying, “Nobody would know… ‘last I
saw him, Ultron was sitting on him!’”
The line was one of the funniest in the film
and one that Renner came up with all on his
own.
Chris Pratt in Guardians of the Galaxy
In 2014 when James Gunn’s Guardians of the
Galaxy released, many fans of the Marvel movies
were introduced to a plethora of new heroes.
And while these characters are well known
to the comic book world, movie goers left
the theaters a bit confused.
Gunn and Chris Pratt decided to have some
fun with the character’s obscurity.
The scene in question is when Peter Quill
is first captured and he is disappointed that
no one recognizes the name of Star-Lord.
The scene, surprisingly, was improvised and
was a nice way for the audience to empathize
with the character about his unimportance.
Those are our picks for 10 hilarious movie
scenes that were totally made up on the spot.
Do you know of any other improvised scenes
that we missed?
Let us know in the comments section below
and don’t forget to subscribe to our channel
for more fun video – like this one!